locals love to sing the praises of a lot
but as lovely as this part of Sweden is
many people are moving away
ricard oland is one of those who plan to
stay who see a future for themselves
here Olin all is a lot handle or general
store a dying breed in modern Sweden he
and his wife sinica have been running
the shop in Silla road for over two
decades in the summer they like to eat
breakfast here you yeah nami of the this
is my world my life in the mornings Olin
bakes bread and rolls and stock shelves
he does it every day in the high season
he employs three people including on
Brit torgersen I'd likely not find other
work so it's good the store exists but
the land handle is more than a place to
buy groceries here people can borrow and
return books pick up their mail and send
packages they can even purchase
pre-ordered medication lon Tyndall enjoy
a long tradition in Sweden Scylla roads
general store now boasts a small cafe to
sinica Olin dreamed of opening 14 years
but up half the headaches I've only had
the cafe two years we're still finding
the right balance but we now have a real
kitchen and serve lunch so the cafe has
become a meeting place for women from
the area here they can find most
everything they need
we can even order snaps and pick it up a
tree cards the ohlins are among the few
who've managed to keep their store as a
float most of the small factories or
craftsmen's workshops that once operated
here in bar blond closed their doors
long ago the general stores are usually
the last to shut down this one and
Leonard's force went out of business
earlier this year the locks in the
center of town draw tourists to the area
in the summer but otherwise there's not
much happening here in remote parts of
Sweden people need to travel long
distances just to do a little shopping
it's not unusual to spend an hour
driving to a store so a Ricard Olin
offers a special delivery service once a
week he makes the rounds
many of his customers are senior
citizens like 91 year old Crooked strum
never even thought that so they are can
eat though SSO what my woobie I have
pain in my legs and shoulders and can't
drive a car anymore Gandhi Khel so it's
good that Rick card comes to me say that
the girl just get the Omni on top oh
yeah hey don't know you know they don't
know over the last decade one in every
three lon Tyndall in Sweden has closed
but now you money and fiber optic cable
are to transform them into digital
service centers at the Olin shop
customers can do their banking or even
apply for a building permit but Johanna
who has a summer job here doubts that'll
be enough to keep young people here long
overdue book had many leave the area
because there simply aren't any jobs a
few work over in Norway and at least
come home on weekends still regard Olin
is not giving up next year he plans to
open a small B&B in a scrapped railway
car he's full of ideas oh my god for me
I'd let a hack did nothing if I can
convince young people that this place is
important and worse hanging onto then I
all have done a good job and been truly
successful the oil he gots to go sitting
outdoors on a summer night Olin knows
why he goes to all this trouble life is
beautiful here embo me thrown by Rimmel
and your tornai and
uh